pour mercy jimmy bonjour karine barclays
bonjour bertrand merci d'être présente
dans ce studio vous êtes directrice
d'une agence événementielle d'affaires
et vous êtes présidente fondatrice de
pavillons afrique au festival de cannes
voilà et on va rajouter que vous êtes
donc une martiniquaise qui a réussi à
l'international racontez-nous d'abord en
résumé karine barclays votre parcours
eh bien écoutez comme beaucoup
d'antillais j'ai quitté la martinique un
peu avant mes 18 ans pour faire mes
études et donc j'ai beaucoup ensuite
vécu à l'étranger en espagne en pologne
en angleterre bon j'en oublie
certainement
et donc ça a toujours été un peu ce qui
me porte vraiment d'aller vers les
autres
et voilà depuis quelques années donc
j'ai travaillé à dubaï sur des gros des
gros projets événementiels et pour la
première fois j'ai créé un vrai
événement à moi qui ai pavillon afrique
au festival de cannes et tout au long de
l'année également alors on va on va
parler de deux pavillons afrique au
festival de cannes
mais cette vocation internationale parce
que il faut quand même que je dise que
vous êtes polyglotte parce que vous avez
vous c'est vrai mais vous avez quand
même ça voilà polyglotte donc vous
parler plusieurs langues y certainement
l'anglais l'espagnol évidemment madrid
le portugais le russe voilà vous êtes
diplômé entre autres d'un troisième
cycle en commerce international et vous
intervenez donc dans l'organisation
d'événements d'affaires à
l'international cette vocation à
l'international elle est l'aînée comment
aussi quand on est né en martinique et
qu'on arrive ailleurs dans le monde
à l'âge de 17 ans je ne sais pas comment
comment elle est née en tout cas j'ai
commencé à travailler à voyager à l'âge
de six ans et je crois que ça m'est
toujours resté jeu l'étranger m'attire
je sais pas comment expliquer à
l'étranger c'est que je ne connais pas
matière voilà on va dire ça de manière
plus large de l'accord par curiosité
naturelle alors venons en à ce défi que
vous avez relevé et réussi un de ces
dernières années c'est ce pavillon
afrique alors afrique au pluriel afrique
s à la fin pourquoi exactement j'y tiens
toujours
parce que c'est une manière d'inclure
toutes les diasporas africaines tous les
afro descendants donc quand on dit
pavillon afrique ça inclut bien sûr les
antilles ce que moi je suis antillaise
et donc il était hors de question que je
fasse pavillon juste pour l'afrique même
si l'afrique c'est déjà plus d'un
milliard de personnes
mais bien sûr je je je compte
j'espère attirer aussi les cinéastes des
professionnels du film des antilles pour
qu'ils puissent être un peu plus connu à
l'étranger et qu'ils puissent trouver
aussi un moyen de monétiser leurs
contenus
alors ces pavillons afrique au festival
de cannes donc le plus prestigieux des
festivals cinématographiques qui se
déroule donc dans cette ville du sud de
la france
alors c'est de ce pavillon afrique c'est
une plateforme qui permet de montrer
donc le le potentiel cinématographique
africain et des diasporas khumbu comme
vous l'avait dit et aussi de connecter
donc les intervenants pour un échange de
ressources détenu justement comment
fonctionne ce alors ce pavillon donc pas
vient afrique et or est une plateforme
qui existent tout au long de l'année ont
fait on a des podcasts on a des
événements en trimestriels ont fait des
sessions de peach et cetera mais bien
entendu kahn qui est le festival le plus
de l'amour du monde
on devait ans devait y être parce que
moi je fais toujours des événements qui
ont un sens et qu'ils sont prestigieux
parce que je pense que nous souvent les
noirs on suit un peu à l'extérieur et
souvent les gens disent oh le pavillon
afrique en marge du festival de cannes
échoue à chaque fois répété jusqu'à
maintenant
non c'est au coeur du festival de cannes
parce qu'on mérite d'y être et donc
c'est un endroit
c'est une des tentes blanches
certainement tous ceux qui regardent
souvent le festival de cannes c'est donc
dans une des tentes blanches et là sous
cette tente il y à des formations du
networking parce que ça compte beaucoup
dans cette profession de rencontrer des
gens qu'on n'aurait jamais rencontré
sinon il y à des master classes il y a
des
des panels de discussion sur des sujets
d'intérêt comme common market et son
produit comme on le ventre comment créer
une co production à ces terrains mais ça
a été facile de mettre ça en place et
est ce que finalement au festival de
cannes vous avez réussi à convaincre les
uns et les autres parce que on sait qu'
il ya des comédiens et des comédiennes
antillaises ou africains dernièrement
qui sont intervenus publiquement pour
dire que l'exercice de leur métier est
difficile en europe et en france en
particulier on le sait donc comment a
été accueillie finalement cette idée de
d'exploser comme ça le cinéma d afrique
comment répondre à ça le le faite vous
avez des fiat est quand même certains
l'organisation du festival de cannes
voudrait voulait avoir quelqu'un une
présence africaine forte depuis de
longues années
on dit depuis plus de vingt ans il
aurait bien souhaité avoir quelque chose
de fort donc il était très content
d'avoir cette initiative
la seule partie difficile c'était
d'attirer des sponsors parce que d'une
certaine manière culture et afrique ça
faisait un peu à financer certains
c'était peut-être pas une bonne manière
de s'associe à sa voix voilà exactement
donc c'est la difficulté mais seulement
quand j'ai une idée en tête je la fais
je ne me pose pas la question de savoir
comment j'aurais reçu parce que j'ai
souvent été une preuve
une première à faire telle chose ou à
faire un tel autre chose mais je ne me
pose jamais inquiets mais l'intention
c'est ici que peut-être quelque part
chez vous de vouloir
justement comment dirais-je dépasser ces
clichés des médias s'élève à coucher
mais bien sûr c'est pour ça que sur le
noir tout à fait voilà et c'est pour ça
que je tenais à être au festival de
cannes dans le festival de cannes pas à
faire un événement dans son hôtel à côté
etc et on ait été le pavillon le plus
couru de cannes pour la première édition
quand on sait la compétition la
concurrence et en 2009 2010
voilà donc quand on sait la compétition
qui a entre plus de 170 pays je crois
donc les gens venaient ils ont faim ils
ont soif d'autre chose d'autre contenu
seulement il faut ouvrir les portes pour
savoir comment contacter les bonnes
personnes pour pour faire éclater son
talent pur jeu par le ddd des
professionnels du film et c'est là parce
que les américains se sont ils sont
vraiment partie prenante du pavillon
afrique
il était là en masse les américaines
avec un noir parce qu'en fait il y en
pavillon américain
mais il ya des gens qui sont très connus
des noirs qui sont connus aux états unis
il n'était jamais venu à cannes il ne se
sentait pas de faire partie du pavillon
américain
et ils ont vu pavillon afrique mais ils
sont venus en nombre et en ce moment
j'ai des demandes de stations de t&d des
états unis de plates formes etc qui
demandent des contenus africains et qui
me demandent aussi des contenus
antillais parce que évidemment la
question qui vient à l'esprit
maintenance et quid du cinéma entier que
ce que vous faites pour faire la
promotion également du cinéma antillais
alors on dit antillais et guyanais et
plus largement même du cinéma de la
caraïbe quoi oui la jamaïque était venu
elle était présente officiellement le il
attire jeans monde chez eux il attire
vraiment d'aider donc moi je voudrais
bien il ya un bureau tournage ici avec
jésus bouddha
il est venu aussi au pavillon afrique
pas officiellement mes livres passé il
était très souvent sous le pavillon il
ya des personnes du cnt dont madame jose
luiz luisa je quittais qui était
également présente
donc j'espère que cette année ils sont
présents de manière officielle et qui
pourront vraiment attirer les cinéastes
dc pos donc c'est quel objectif aussi de
votre à bord ni de suture ibis ou avant
l'appel analyser ce qui compte a
contacté nous contactez moi sur pavillon
afrik.com infos @ pavillon afrique avec
s.com si vous avez des contenus déjà à
tourner des documentaires etc ou encore
si vous avez un projet que vous
souhaiter financer puisque l'âge et des
américains financer des projets à bon
entendeur salut plus largement dehors du
cinéma
est-ce que vos dents dans
dans vous avec votre agence
événementielle d'affaires est ce que là
aussi vous souhaitez intervenir
davantage dans notre champ j'ai déjà
essayé ici on le rappelle et grandit si
je suis martiniquaise pur jus comme on
dit même si j'ai beaucoup vécu à
l'étranger mais j'ai essayé quelques
fois de faire des projets parce que
c'est parce qu'il manque un après ce qui
ce qui les idées ne manquent pas ce qui
manque après c'est réalisé c'est avoir
des gens qui hantent les bombes ou
l'envi où l'intérêt parce que c'est vrai
que je propose toujours des choses qui
sont un peu en avance mais et
quelquefois ça ne sonne ça ne prend pas
ici bon ça a pris ailleurs ça a pas pris
mais j'écris des propositions je sais
pas ce que parce que votre travail je
crois consiste un petit peu avec cette
agence événementielle d'affaires s'est
créé de nouvelles opportunités pour des
entreprises même des gouvernements
locaux ou qui ont du mal à se lancer
seul sur de nouveaux marchés à
l'international tu as fait et donc ça
pourrait intéresser potentiellement oui
oui oui je sais bien mais je dois dire
que je n'ai pas les clés bon je ne sais
pas mais vraiment génial d'être en
appelle certainement lancé vous êtes de
passage en martinique
bon vous le prolonger parce que c'est
pas évident de rentrer en france dans le
contexte actuel mais vous repartirez
bientôt de sept îles pour quoi faire et
puis reviendrez vous avec un ou deux
projets c'est la conclusion
eh bien je vais bientôt repartir oui en
fait pour continuer la préparation de
pavie en afrique peut-être faire quelque
chose avec la mairie de paris toujours
autour du cinéma et je peux avoir
beaucoup de projets les vraiment les
idées ne manquent pas et j'espère qu'un
jour je vais arriver à faire quelque
chose avec mon île on verra bien eh bien
c'est ce qu'on vous souhaite
voilà c'est sur cette note d'espoir que
nous concluons cet entretien merci
karine et bonne fin de séjour dans votre
île natale
à bientôt